[Musik]
satz aufschlag und da ganz besonders der
erste aufschlag natürlich ist eine
riesen macht
in meinen augen geht das ganze erstmal
los mit den beinen sascha ist ein sehr
sehr guter athlet und hat über die jahre
unglaubliche krafttraining gemacht für
die beine und man sieht ja auch das fast
schon schick in der luft und hat
eigentlich gar schon soviel exklusiv
kraft und und ob kommen dann noch seinen
langen hebel seine langen arme er bleibt
schön lange gerade oben er hat den kopf
lange oben und hat oben dann sehr gutes
handgelenk womit deponiert und dann
wieso einpeitschen effekt bekommt und
dadurch kriegt diese ganze
geschwindigkeit rein der staat wie
gesagt sind die beine das sollte man
sich genau angucken weil er so weit oben
ist und dadurch natürlich auch ein
tollen minkel hat und dadurch wird der
ball noch massiv stärker und schneller
ein hobbyspieler sollte sich auf jeden
fall den rhythmus genau angucken wie der
sascha startet und dann halt mit der
bewegung wie er den schritt macht die
beine legt und dann maximal nach oben
springt das kann man natürlich
unterstützen mit krafttraining für die
beine hat aber dann auch noch einen
kreativen aspekt den man trainieren muss
und man sollte immer probieren dass man
wenn man im feld landet nicht nach links
fällt und dass man ein deutliches stück
ich würde jetzt mal sagen 10 cm im feld
landet man könnte sich theoretisch der
hütchen hinlegen oder linien dass man
also nach vorne drüber springen muss und
die ganze kraft geht oben zum treffpunkt
[Musik]
die kerbe hatten ganz speziellen schlag
wo sie aus der defensive sich loest und
wie viele profis geht sie natürlich tief
und flach um diesen ball zu kontern um
da maximal viel stabilität der
schwierigen lage zu haben bei der angie
ist es halt sehr sehr extrem weil sie
wirklich ganz unten in der hocke ist und
mit den knien fast am boden denke ich
kommt das von ihrem schlechten zweiten
aufschlag gehen sie oft nur ein spielt
und dann schlägt direkt eine wenn die
spieler ihr dann das ding auf dem fuß
nagel knallen dann muss sie runter und
irgendwie diesen ball noch zurück
bringen und das zeigt sie ihr talent
aber auch ihre physische fitness dass
sie halt mit einem tiefen schwerpunkt
den ball neutralisiert
ein hobbyspieler sollte auch hier
schauen dass er sich das positive ab
guckt dass er untergeht dass er stabil
bleibt und dass er den ball übers netz
spielt also der schlechte fehler wäre
bei intel netzfehler man muss tief gehen
in die hocke würde ich jetzt eher
verneinen und auch gerade für ältere
leute das wäre dann ein bisschen zu viel
aber ein tiefer schwerpunkt und sehr
sehr wenig mit dem arm zu machen dass
man wirklich nur kurzer rückschwung und
mit dem handgelenk drüber geht und nicht
groß ausholt und wirklich schlägt
sondern meinem blog diesem wald zurück
grafs vorhand ist einzigartig weil
natürlich keiner so spielt wie er ich
denke viele spieler haben sich da was
abgeschaut im defensiven bereich wenn
man also keine zeit hat dass man den
ball hoch zieht mit viel spin spielt
außer defensive um wiederum zeit zu
gewinnen um schnell zur mitte zurück zu
kommen
als linkshänder macht das natürlich noch
viel mehr sinn weil ich den ball mit dem
gegner hoch in die rückhand spielen kann
das ist ja einer seiner besten bälle ich
hatte den ton dabei gefragt wie dieser
schlag denn zustande gekommen ist und er
sagt zu mir dass dieser form ball im
training verboten ist dass er wirklich
sauber schwingen soll hier bis an die
schulter rand man habe aber wo kommt der
denn her der schlag und da hat der toni
mir erklärt dass er alex der hat mit 15
monte carlo gespielt bei den herren der
ball kommt so schnell so hart mit soviel
treffer war zu spät und konnte sich
nicht anders retten als in ihren zu
ziehen weil er keine zeit mehr hatte
darüber zu gehen und da kommt dieser
ball her perfektioniert hat er ihn
kopiert hat den bisher nicht wirklich
jemand glaube auch nicht dass er
wirklich kopiert wird aber wie gesagt in
der defensiven variante wird er von
vielen spielern jetzt gespielt und da
ist er sich ehrlich ein vorbild
der schwung der wird er über den kopf
gezogen und geht um den fall der nicht
damit produzieren kann dass ich den ball
also eine ganz andere flugkurve gebe da
brauche ich unglaublich viel kraft im
arm im handgelenk und auch im bauch um
das hinzubekommen und das timing ist
natürlich wahnsinnig schwer
dieser schlag ist sehr schwer zu
kopieren und ich habe bisher noch keinen
gesehen der ihn wirklich kopiert
[Musik]
er spart die hatte als junge spielerin
einen trainer der selber sehr klassisch
gespielt hat chip charts sehr flach
gespielt hat und deswegen hat schon
erspart die in frühen jahren ihren slice
sehr gut ausgebaut und den slice ball
den spielt sie wirklich sehr sehr gut
und sehr stabil und ansatzlos kommt auf
einmal an der stopp
professionelle spielerinnen auf der tour
sind meistens stark in den grundlinien
und starken vorhand und rückhand und
ganz besonders die beidhändige rückhand
und erspart sie hat mit ihrem slice
anschlag der nicht so oft vorkommt
ähnlich wie steffi graf natürlich und
der stopp ball ist halt ein ball gegen
den wenige spielerinnen wirklich gerne
spielen und die profispielerin sind
meistens fühlen sie sich wohl an der
grundlinie und gehen nicht so gerne ans
netz und so mit diesem ball forciert
erspart die sie nach vorne und bringt
sie halten lagen wo sie eigentlich sich
nicht so wohl fühlen und passiert sie
das
hobby spieler können sich davon
abschauen positionierungen platz
position des spielers wo spiele ich
welchen ball und da kann ich über diesen
slice mit einer guten länge kann ich den
gegner hinten halten und ihn dann im
richtigen moment nach vorne holen man
sollte sich wie gesagt genau die platz
position angucken keine kurzem bälle
spielen wenn man hinter der grundlinie
ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
roger federers rückhand wie viele seiner
schläge ist der elegante mich geht es
mal lohnt es gibt ja auch viele fotos wo
man ihn mit einem ballett vergleicht
weil er halt in der luft steht und sehr
graziös schwingt wenn man mal auf die
technischen details achtet roger hohl
ist sehr frühe aus hat also sehr schnell
den schlägerkopf hinten kommt über eine
sehr schnelle rotation und lässt auge
und kopf sehr sehr lange auf den
treffpunkt also man sieht bei roger auch
auf vielen fotos das also in dem moment
wo er den ball trifft ist der kopf und
die augen auf dem treffen sind und das
ist bei vielen spielern auch bei den
vielen amateuren ist es halt so die
gucken halt schon wo sie hinschlagen und
sind im treffpunkt mit dem kopf gar
nicht mehr hier
[Musik]
der nächste akt wäre dann sein
handgelenk wo er sehr sehr stark ist und
wo er im treffpunkt mit dem handgelenk
darüber zieht um den ball diesen drei
zugeben ja also da sieht man klar dass
er also vorne legt mit dem gewicht und
im treffpunkt kommt dann hier dieses
handgelenk und dann kommt der hohe aus
schwung dass ich da halt maximal drei
kriege um den ball zu kommen beim roger
sieht es leicht und einfach aus und bei
vielen hobbyspielern sieht das
angestrengt aus fest und 40 will
bewegung weniger ist hier mehr wir
wollen ruhe im schlag hamm die linke
hand führt nach hinten aus dass ich hier
dieses stabilität habe und da einfach
die ruhe im treffpunkt
[Musik]
novak djokovic ist der besten spieler
der welt weil erstens mal die zahlen und
statistiken dafür zählen er macht einen
wahnsinnig guten job gute und starke
aufschläger in die bedrängnis zu bringen
indem er viele aufschläge blockt es ist
kein schlag es ist ein geblockter schlag
er rotiert sehr sehr gut mit der hüfte
dreht sich im treffpunkt kommt er bei
dem rückhand return mit der linken hand
und bleibt sehr stabil er ist sehr stark
im bauch und in den beinen und viele
teile des returns werden mit dem körper
auch gemacht gar nicht wirklich so sehr
mit der hand
der hobbyspieler kann sich von nowak
abschauen zuerst mal die vorbereitung
für den return dass sein sogenanntes
split step also ich habe ungefähr 1 2
zentimeter über der luftlande mit beiden
füßen gleich breit mehr als
schulterbreiten und das sollte geteilt
werden mit dem treffpunkt des aufschlags
und dann wird eingeleitet die
ausholbewegung mit eingeleitet über die
hüfte rotation also nicht über den arm
sondern über die hüfte rotation und dann
gibt es die gewichtsverlagerung und im
treffpunkt wie gesagt sehr sehr starker
bauch kunden bleiben nicht reißen
sondern stabil bleiben und im treffpunkt
mit der linken hand nach vorne führen
und mit dem kopf lange drauf bleiben das
sind eigentlich so die konnte
[Musik]